[Musique]
rares sont les journalistes à avoir fait
le déplacement car le village enclavé
dans batelain est à 350 km de la
capitale et un tiers de la route quasi
impraticable nécessite une pirogue et
une moto
c'est dans cette petite commune du
sud-est de Madagascar que le drame a eu
lieu le 29 août dernier les villageois
découvrent le corps de Florette tuer
lors du kidnapping de son fils d'un an
atteint d'albinisme un enlèvement
d'autant plus inquiétant que ces
dernières années plusieurs rapports font
état d'une recrudescence des meurtres
d'albinos en Afrique impliquant des
mutilations à des fins rituels
le corps de Fleurette a été retrouvé ici
c'est là que je l'ai trouvé sans vie
c'était là qu'elle cuisinait personne
n'avait touché à ses affaires une partie
de sa tête a été retrouvée ici
les habitants de montent alors à la
gendarmerie de leur livrer les suspects
demande refuser mais la foule insiste et
franchit le cordon de sécurité pour
pénétrer dans la caserne zone interdite
au public les forces de l'ordre tir
certains sont touchés à la tête une
vingtaine de personnes est abattue
cet hôpital situé à 100 km est le seul
de la zone à pouvoir traiter les
blessures graves l'évacuation doit se
faire par hélicoptère mais de jour après
les meute les blessés ne sont toujours
pas là
les blessés légers sont soignés dans ce
petit hôpital à proximité du village
c'est le cas d'Esther qui a été blessé à
la jambe c'est la mort de sa sœur qui a
déclenché les meute
les habitants sont venus et ont demandé
gentiment aux gendarmes donnez-nous les
suspects et on s'en va les gendarmes
nous ont répondu allez-y rentrez si vous
voulez récupérer les personnes que vous
cherchez
ils ont mis un cordon de sécurité et si
on le dépassait il serait obligé de nous
tirer dessus nous avons franchi le
cordon et ils nous ont tiré dessus
immédiatement
lors d'une conférence de presse le
secrétaire d'État à la gendarmerie
affirme que des tirs de sommation ont
été effectués et invoquent la légitime
défense
ils étaient obligés
de tous
sur place personne ne soutient cette
version après la caserne les habitants
sont prennent au domicile du grand-père
de l'enfant disparu il est soupçonné de
l'avoir vendu avec la complicité de
trois membres de la famille
ici c'était son épicerie où il y avait
la marchandise c'était une maison à
étage en bas c'était son domicile
les habitants se sont vengés et ont
récupéré toutes ses affaires et ça
marchandise même les bouteilles en
plastique tous les habitants de la
commune
les habitants trouvent des éléments
troublants chez le grand-père comme ce
papier mentionnant des signes
astrologiques et plusieurs messages
codés laissant croire à la pratique d'un
art divinatoire
où les fans il a appris la voyance et
une fois qu'il a maîtrisé la discipline
il a écrit sur un papier comme celui-ci
toutes les personnes qui sont décédées
dans ce village mais les habitants l'ont
déjà brûlé
le grand-père avait déjà été arrêté à
plusieurs reprises notamment pour vol
d'ossement humain puis libéré après de
courtes peines une Clémence qui a
renforcé les soupçons de corruption
les habitants ont attaqué la caserne de
gendarmerie parce que souvent la plupart
des suspects sont libérés et on ne sait
pas pour quelle raison
c'est pour cela que la population a
décidé de les tuer eux-mêmes
la famille des victimes se doutait que
les suspects allaient être libérés après
l'interrogatoire c'est pour cette raison
que les habitants ont choisi la justice
populaire ils n'ont plus confiance dans
les juges et la gendarmerie
[Musique]
dans un esprit d'apaisement et de paix
la gendarmerie a offert quatre zébus aux
familles des victimes mais cela n'a pas
atténué la colère
avec les autorités qui travaillent ici à
ikongo si tu veux tuer quelqu'un tu
payes
les autorités prennent l'argent de les
assassins puis les libèrent
ce sont d'autres personnes qui ont fait
du mal mais ce sont nos enfants qu'ils
ont tué pourquoi n'ont-ils pas tué les
malfaiteurs
demandons à l'état de nous protéger car
les forces de l'ordre ont abattu nos
familles et aucune mesure n'est prise
les gendarmes auteurs des tirs ont fui
la commune et ont été remplacés l'Union
européenne a immédiatement condamné
l'usage excessif de la violence et
appelé à une enquête indépendante mais
c'est à la gendarmerie que l'enquête a
été confiée depuis le drame le directeur
régional de la sécurité publique et le
chef de district ont été limogés
l'enfant albinos qui nappé et le
grand-père cerveau présumé reste
introuvable